hello everyone and welcome back to
versus the show that takes art and makes
it competitive much in the same way that
andy takes toys and makes them cowboys
astronauts and evil hams i'm your ham
and host mark ellis and today's episode
features the two tinseltown talents
behind the best toys in the chest tom
hanks and tim allen oh no i can't bear
to watch one of these again tom is
america's dad and provides the voice of
woody in the toy story films tim allen
plays buzz lightyear in those films and
is known as america's uncle
tv dad are you crazy sorry homer simpson
maybe we'll go with america's handyman
wow
that's deep so in one corner you have
the hanks and fun fact he's making his
third appearance on this show not in
studio again and he's not gonna be
showing up anytime soon that's probably
due to the fact that he's owen two in
his versus career so far i guarantee you
that he'll do a better job than last
time most recently taking an l to none
other than denzel washington
but tom has a great shot here as his
entire career is once again going to be
considered but he's not going up against
a nobody he's literally taking on joe
somebody
maybe they're getting it on a subliminal
level you're gonna have a lot of those
references so try to keep up i don't
have time to coach you through each wink
and nod the way that friendly neighbor
wilson might coach tim taylor through
life on home improvement which is the
show that rocketed tim allen to super
stardom
you get that
rocket astronaut i don't get it
you want cultured swine
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office round two tomato
meter slash audience core round three
mount everest round four legacy
and then we'll do a wild card round to
settle the score once and for all who
knows what could pop up there maybe
chris evans checks in after all he
provides the voice of play here in the
upcoming pixar film based on the real
astronaut it was the basis for the
toilet year voiced by tim allen but the
real astronaut never existed either so
if he's pretend then the toy would be
double not real which somehow cancels
out and makes the toy actually in
existence excuse me i i think the word
you're searching for is space ranger and
you could probably go buy a buzzer woody
toy at any store nationwide so in the
imagination of kids of all ages all over
the world that cowboy and that star man
are just as real as you and me i don't
have time for this man we got deep and
it's not even round one yet all right
folks strap in and saddle up we're about
to go to infinity beyond and the old
west all while staying in andy's room
i won't be that that'd be weird let's
get it
on all right all right all right all
right all right all right all right all
right time for the song and dance round
one box office
since tom hanks played a comedian in the
1980s dramedy punchline and both tim
allen and your humble host are actual
stand-up comedians you're just like me
trash we all subscribe to the philosophy
that you gotta be honest so truth be
told tom hanks has a huge advantage in
this round perfect
why well did you just hear the name i
said he's tom hanks he's been so vital
to movie theaters for decades they
should build a statue of him or at least
put a giant piano in the lobby so he can
jump on it if he feels so inclined but
tim allen's been in plenty of hit movies
and generated ratings and record numbers
on the small screen so this round might
get a little snug
no no way tom had his big screen
breakthrough first in the summer of 1984
when both splash and bachelor party
became solid box office hits raking in a
combined haul of 100 million dollars
then in 1988 he did that piano jumping
little kid becoming an adult thing and
big took in 151 million dollars around
the world
the next year's turner and hooch would
tack on 71 million dollars to his career
earnings but that's not why it's being
mentioned did you know that tim allen
was offered that role and turned it down
he was also considered for the robin
williams part in dead poets society and
passed that up why well probably because
he foresaw the millions of bucks he'd
bring in as tim the tool man taylor on
the hit sitcom home improvement the show
was an instant rating smash with 28.9
million folks tuning in every week for
its first season home improvement would
go on to regularly have over 30 million
souls watching for subsequent seasons
and in its eighth and final season
finale
35.5 million people swung by the
taylor's house mostly to say bye to
jonathan taylor thomas but allen was
just getting set for his next act movie
stardom his three starring roles as the
santa claus all grossed over 100 million
dollars each with the first installment
delivering over 190 million reasons to
be joyful
allen also had hits with the beloved
galaxy quest which grossed 90 million
dollars and the less than beloved
christmas with the cranks which took in
96 million dollars say what you want but
the guy knows how to make a buck at the
season of giving if you're trying to
make me feel guilty get off of it which
brings us to toy story twas a revolution
in animation and cinema when the debut
film was released in 1995 and it was a
huge hit making 365 million dollars
the second film ingeniously titled toy
story 2 was an even huger hit crushing
it to the tune of 511 million dollars
and the applause grows a little bit then
some time passed andy grew up and in
2010 toy story 3 came out and grossed
over a billion dollars toy story 4 also
crossed that billion buck barricade
becoming the franchise's all-time top
earner so far aside from playing buzz
lightyear tim allen's biggest hit at the
box office was not about a jolly guy
from the north pole it was playing a guy
who just wanted to go on one last
joyride with his buddies wild hogs was a
monster hit in 2007 revving up 253
million dollars worldwide does tom hanks
have anything on his resume to match
that can we get serious now yes yes yes
he does forrest gump made over 600
million dollars the da vinci code made
over 700 million dollars saving private
ryan and castaway did over 400 million
dollars catch me if you can and apollo
13 grossed over 300 million dollars and
have we arrived at the point yet today
tim allen has made nine movies that took
in at least 100 million dollars tom
hanks has starred in 29 such films
so this is an easy win for the hanks
right
not so fast yes he's grossed over 10
billion in film money for his career so
far and that crushes tim allen's total
of 4.72 billion dollars but tim actually
has the higher average gross at the
multiplex making 236 million dollars per
flick to tom's 212 million dollars per
film so while hanks clearly has had more
success over his career on the silver
screen he's also had over twice the
amount of played appearances that allen
has the tool man was busy making home
improvement one of the most popular
shows of the 1990s and one of the
biggest sitcoms ever for reference tim
allen's salary his final season was 1.25
million dollars a quarter of a million
more than jerry seinfeld was making
around the same time tom hanks became
the movie star of the 90s no question
but the rarer feat in my opinion is
being able to dominate any size screen
for that time period and tim allen's
more recent run of last man standing
drew solid numbers for nine total
seasons all things considered this round
is going to score a major upset and make
you all think hanks is gonna go 0-3 in
his versus career we're not there yet
where we are is tim allen getting the
point in round number one and he goes up
one to nothing i feel much better
round two tomato meter slash audience
score
tim allen may be good at fixing toilets
and even better at grunting like a pig
but he's great at pulling upsets in this
show so far i know a lot of you are
upset about how round one shook out but
the guy's an underdog and he came out
swinging against a very angry tom hanks
i mean he's not actually angry right we
haven't told we told tom hanks he's 0-2
on this show
do you have to keep bringing that up
can't you
just forget it
america's dad may have a goose egg in
the win column so far but he's received
plenty of w's from the critics circle
both the tomato meter and the audience
score are quite fond of tommy but how do
they feel about timmy and for that
matter forky woody buzzy you're mocking
me aren't you well much like round one
toy story is at the top of the resume
for both of these combatants here as
well toy story and toy story 2 are both
perfecto on the tomato meter 100
whereas part 3 rests at 98 percent and
part 4 resides at 97 percent it's the
best punch hanks or allen throw in their
entire tomato meter career although tom
hanks also has big at 97 percent and
while tim allen only has galaxy quest
also in the 90s hanks has catch me if
you can apollo 13 a good day in the
neighborhood captain phillips saving
private ryan that thing you do and
bridge of spies all at least 91 percent
oh and uh splash is also 91 which is one
point above galaxy quest although
they're both equally preposterous that
time you just backed off you
you fin-headed monstrosity which begs
the question would you rather date a
mermaid or save the galaxy i don't know
how to swim much to every inner child
chagrin tim allen's first foray into the
fireproof boots of santa claus is only
at 73 on the tomato meter that's still
fresh but the ref clearly took a few
points away because i guess it's a
personal foul to you know murder the
previous santa claus did not we all saw
the footage tim you're guilty it wasn't
my fault the other guy fell it was an
accident i've got homeowners insurance
and a good attorney tim allen also
narrated the nature doc chimpanzee and
he was in the martial arts film red belt
he's in that and they're also fresh and
they're the only other fresh movies on
his resume how about the hanks yeah we
got plenty of sweet smelling cinema over
yonder castaway's at 89 percent the post
and news of the world are both at 88 and
they both have newspapers and
philadelphia is tied with a league of
their own at 80 percent look tom hanks
thrives in fresh territory the green
mile and saving mr banks are 79 each
boris gump is at 70
and would you believe that all three of
his starring vehicles alongside
america's sweetheart meg ryan are fresh
sleepless in seattle is at 75 which
seems a little low you've got males at
69 percent which is a little bit low and
joe versus volcano
well that's lucky to be as high as 65
what what are you talking about look we
were all sad when meg's first bow goose
ate it in top gun but tom hanks was
right there to grab the rebound
tom does have a few duds including big
hits like the robert langdon da vinci
trilogy whose best effort angels and
demons only climb to 37 well this is
really fun
and helpful
and hank's lowest effort of all time the
tomato meter is
the bonfire of the vanities at 16
percent if you have opinions about
anything i want to encourage you to
express them don't be shy that's not
good but it's still better than tim
allen's wild hogs which is at 14
and that's higher than christmas with
the cranks currently at five percent why
did i say currently like is anybody else
going to review christmas with the
cranks and get it back up to fresh it's
over cranks get a new holiday
the good news for alan is that wild hogs
pulls a man on fire with the audience
score and roars back into a 61 fresh
rating his best four flicks on the
metric are still the toy stories and
then we get galaxy quest at 79 percent
but tom hanks is be loved by everyone
and we're all as children even though
most of us don't get to live at his
house he's got two movies that are
actually ahead of toy story 4's 94 on
the audience score you want to guess
what they are
take a shot while i remind you that toy
story 2 is the lowest of the four toy
story films on the audience score at 87
percent all right you had enough time to
guess or cheat and look up the answer
forrest gump and saving private ryan are
both at 95 percent this guy's more fresh
than old spice and his averages on both
measurement sticks prove it his per film
tomato meter average is 68 percent and
the audience score says 66 percent
meanwhile tim allen saves face but is
still rotten at 50 percent of the tomato
meter and 53 on the audience score and a
few tool time viewers were hoping for a
miracle comeback thanks to that beloved
sitcom home improvement
i got nothing for you the audience
scores 69 which is hilarious and also
nowhere near close enough to sway this
round in favor of allen tom hanks
answers the bell here and he evens to
score it one to one as we head into the
next round i'm actually excited about
this round three mount everest
okay truth be told as great as these
performers may be and as much as we may
love their toy story characters neither
tom hanks or tim allen have actually
been to the summit of mount everest
refresh my memory will you please what
exactly have you done in the past five
years i don't believe buzz lightyear or
woody have either but if they raced my
money's on the guy with the jet pack
tom and tim may have never been to the
literal mountaintop but in terms of
entertainment they've both reached
dizzying heights very few actors ever
have so this round will beg the question
who's had the better peak that one
shining moment when you were on the top
of your game and no one else in the
industry could touch you or even look
you in the eye mine's happening right
now
you are so much less attractive when i'm
sober
thank goodness it's not that often now
you may have entered this vid thinking
it would be an easy w for tom hanks and
maybe you think he'll at least take this
round in a cakewalk because he does have
a pretty impressive all-time high moment
the dude was nominated for an oscar for
his performance in big which is
incredible because that's a comedy and
the academy uh let's just say they don't
love yuck fests or else eddie murphy and
mel brooks would have shelves full of
oscars by now but then in 1993 tom
started philadelphia and won his first
best actor prize and that wasn't even
his apex nope that would happen the very
next year when tom hanks joined elite
company by winning again for his star
turn and forrest gump that's back to
back best actor victories and with that
hanks joined a club that features less
than 10 all-time members back-to-back
winners are exceedingly rare in any
category at the academy awards much less
for a major category with so much
competition now here's where it gets
kind of eerie when the guy that played
woody was approaching his all-time
greatness buzz was on a legendary tear
of his own forrest gump was released in
theaters in the summer of 1994. later
that november tim allen achieved a feat
that may be even more rare than that of
his colleagues allen was the star of the
number one show in the country home
improvement he was also the star of the
number one film in the country the santa
claus and he had topped the new york
times bestseller list with his book
don't stand too close to a naked man in
the same week tim allen was at the top
of three different mountains
simultaneously the historical precedent
for either set of accomplishments is
relatively new eddie redmayne almost
repeated mahersha ali has won two
statues in three years but back to back
best actor wins in the modern era is the
stuff of legend not even meryl streep
who gets nominated just about every time
she walks on set shame on you has never
done the repeat dance perhaps even more
astonishing is that tom hanks had a
decent shot to get nominated for a third
consecutive year for his portrayal of
astronaut jim level in apollo 13. he
missed out and instead nick cage won the
award for leaving las vegas
which is actually just as tough as
flying a space shuttle whereas tom hanks
was crushing it and continues to tim
allen was playing three different sports
and winning a championship in all of
them at the same time
boy i love hearing you say that and at
that particular point in history home
improvement was the no-brainer the only
place you could escape home improvement
was at the ella's household my dad not a
fan of that show for whatever reason
when that show or wheel of fortune came
on he was like
get it out of my house no idea why but
tim allen could sneak back in any house
he wanted to provided we set out a plate
of cookies for him he was also santa
claus santa is watching his saturated
fats
the transition from tv star to film is a
precarious undertaking but he proved to
be the perfect murderer for old saint
nick and when he stepped into those
boots it was like he belonged there the
whole time you add a best seller into
the vitamix and you have a smoothie only
one other humorist has ever enjoyed back
in the late 1970s john belushi had a
similar week of immortality belushi was
on the number one show saturday night
live starred in the number one movie
animal house and was on the
chart-topping blues brothers album all
at the same time e if only dan aykroyd
had taken that role of d-day both jake
and elwood could have been in the club
together so maybe tom hanks has been
hanging around his mountaintop for
longer but for one magical week in 1994
tim allen was everywhere on your tv in
your bathroom and even stuck in your
chimney
geez when you put it like that i'm glad
all that guy wanted to do is make us
laugh tim allen wins the mount everest
round and he takes a two to one lead
over his fellow sentient toy houston we
have a problem
round four legacy
and now we cease to speak about how good
you had it for a week or a month or one
night when you might have pushed santa
claus off the roof am i belaboring the
point we all watched them push santa
claus right we're going to take a gander
at the entire range of mountains that
you call a career both tim allen and tom
hanks came from comedic backgrounds and
were able to branch out to be regaled as
entertainers for kids of all ages allen
has already pulled a few upset wins
today and really his entire career in
hollywood has been that of an underdog
story one night he was bombing on stage
at a corporate event and by the way
they're always the worst they pay well
but man are they the worst
i smiled
waved my little hat and i did that so
when do i get paid and he was making fun
of how the crowd wasn't paying attention
to him but they were just shoveling food
into their mouths like a bunch of pigs
it amused him that night and from there
his famous men our pigs bit became a
hallmark of 1980 stand up and the
linchpin of his comedic persona leading
to home improvement
conversely tom hanks got his start on a
popular sitcom after dropping out of
college and landing a few parts in
obscure movies hanks and peter scolari
teamed up to form bosom buddies a hit
show with a hook that didn't lend itself
to an extended run like home improvement
but it made enough of an impact where
hanks could start auditioning for better
movie parts lo and behold splash and
bachelor party come along and now we got
us a thriving career in the comedy
section of blockbuster well anything
worth doing is worth doing right
the connective tissue between hanks and
allen is their refusal to stay in the
first box that made them famous alan was
a monster success on tv but he was still
able to make the daunting transition to
movie star and hanks who had become a
movie star by 1988 wasn't content with
just dominating our funny bones so he
made the transition from zany comedies
to romantic comedies to full-on dramas
perhaps as well as anyone in history it
was tom hanks that executed the playbook
of broadening your acting horizons in
fact tom hanks may have actually written
that playbook
so as we take a look back at buzz and
woody who does have the ultimate legacy
tom hanks is certainly easier to sum up
he's america's dad tim allen at times
has been the tv dad to many and santa
claus for multiple generations but as
successful as alan was doing stand-up no
one's going to confuse him with george
carlin or richard pryor or bill burr
those names are some of the best to ever
do it kind of like tom hanks at being a
movie star not to mention that hanks
also directed movies like that thing you
do and produced banner projects like
band of brothers and from the earth to
the moon a show that i'm pretty sure
buzz lightyear would enjoy maybe but not
right now so while tim allen is
certainly secure in his legacy as an
all-time sitcom actor and one of the
greatest toys to ever suit up tom hanks
is simply on another level he makes our
entertainment needle move like few ever
have he's become a part of all of our
families we feel like we know him we
love him and we can't wait to see what
he does next whether it's an all-time
comedy like big a rom-com like sleepless
in seattle a drama like philadelphia or
a little bit of everything with forrest
gump he knocks it out of the stadium
hell we watched a guy stranded on an
island by himself for two hours and it
was mesmerizing so as much as i think
tim the tool man taylor might have been
way more successful surviving on that
island and castaway tom hanks made it
worth checking out he takes a big win in
the legacy round and we're tied up two
to two
and now it's time for the wild card
round toy chest
sorry collectors and ebay proprietors i
meant to say figure or figurine look the
movie's called toy story and since both
tim allen and tom hanks are stars let's
take a look back at just these flicks
and their beloved characters and sort
out once and for all who's the best
child play thing are you team woody or
team buzz
woody certainly had a good head start in
the first toy story when we meet andy's
toys that are luckily not named chucky
it's established that woody is the
sheriff in town he's the favorite of his
human owner and is a great source of
pride for our leader but then a spaceman
named buzz lightyear shows up and throws
woody's ego into disarray we think
they've never seen a new toy before full
disclosure if i'm a kid i'm gonna play
with buzz lightyear more after all we've
been through i can dress myself up like
a western cowboy but this light year
fella has a full astronaut suit can
blast off has wings that work most of
the time that let him fly or fall
gracefully it's everything you want
under the christmas tree shut up just
shut up you idiot and as much as toy
story 2 focuses on woody it's buzz who
saves the day woody is about to be
shipped off to japan courtesy of al's
toy barn but buzz saves the day by
finding al's apartment just in the nick
of time that might have been the easy
part then it's on buzz to appeal to what
he's better judgment convincing him to
stay where he belongs one of the many
reasons that the first two toy story
films earned their perfect 100 tomato
meter scores which not even the
godfathers have is because they so
seamlessly peel back the layers of
rivalry between woody and buzz revealing
a friendship a partnership a kinship and
probably many other ships and i ship
them as a pair they complement each
other and we needed to lay that
groundwork of good-natured rivals to see
who can become the best teammate when
it's all on the line and our toy pals
were never in need of a buzzer beater
more than at the end of toy story 3.
i think this is the best of the bunch i
love them all part 4 was a nice stroll
down memory lane but 3 is what got me in
the feels the most we had a menacing
teddy bear villain voiced by the
incomparable ned beatty where's your kid
now sheriff and it all led to a gaggle
of collectibles preparing to be
incinerated yeah it's a kids movie but
it got dark there for a while and if you
recall buzz lightyear is the first of
the toys to realize that resistance is
futile and we all might as well accept
our fate as goners burning in a pile of
trash
it's not that he gave up the fight it's
that he accepted his destiny and it was
kind of moving but woody kept on
battling and was the last toy in that
scene to call it quits and it's a truly
beautiful moment when buzz lets woody
know that it's okay if they go to the
great beyond as long as they're all
together
and i feel the tears coming it all ended
okay and that emotional climax is just
one of the many instances where buzz
helped woody or woody helped buzz
they're there to one-up each other sure
but more importantly these two pals know
how to get the best out of one another
and that includes a good woody pep talk
when buzz is feeling like his wings are
clipped but the real emotion of toy
story 3 comes after it all works out
okay and andy is going off to college
it's time to say goodbye except to that
one toy that makes the trek for the
first semester woody he was the og the
original share of keeping law and order
together making sure there were no
snakes in any boots and if i'm a kid
give me buzz lightyear all day long but
as the moral compass the leader of the
group and the saver of the day i gotta
go with woody for the best toy on the
shelf assuming mr potato head isn't in
the conversation because that's don
rickles folks youtube the old friars
club roasts he's the best of the bunch
but today it's woody who takes the win
in the wild card round and thus tom
hanks emerges victorious in today's
match this is ideal this is perfect this
is more than perfect i could suggest
they contain my glee all right now i
need to make an apology to wilson i get
it tommy wasn't completely alone on that
island but much like andy with his
beloved pals he eventually had to say
goodbye all's well that ends well
because tom hanks gets his very first
win on verses and it comes to the
expense of a very frisky tim allen
i say we blame the whole evening on rap
music and too much violence on
television he may have lost today but
that whole number one show movie book
thing is pretty damn remarkable who had
the better 1994 tim allen or jim carrey
or tom hanks i
hate to blow my own horn
it's the hanks that's your winner but
that's just my opinion so here's some
questions
i pose to you dear viewer when it comes
to toy story are you going buzz are you
going woody how about iconic big screen
live action characters of your youth are
you going tom hanks and big or tim allen
in the santa claus hit me up on social
media at mark ellis live with your take
and stay tuned right here to rotten
tomatoes for all the latest in the world
of lightyear pixar movies tv
books we doing books now well movies
based on books which if you need an a on
a book report you got to read the book
but if a b is good enough and it should
be just watch the movie you'll be fine
thanks for tuning in to this episode of
versus i'm mark ellis reminding you that
men are pigs they will push a jolly old
man off a roof in cold blood in front of
his own reindeer and okay we get a
little possessive about our childhood
toys time to keep this wagon trainer
moving to where infinity beyond
nah i live in the valley
you